fun fact uh yes a quick one um do you
know that there's
uh obviously because of the situation
now um the pandemic i don't depend on
where you are in the world obviously
um but in the uk currently you still
can't um go to
um like clothes stores and well clothes
clothes stores are closed at the moment
but when they were open at a time
you couldn't try stuff on due to
obviously like yay
contamination but whatever so i saw on
tick tock that as a way you can test
whether jeans or trousers fit you
without putting them on and
it's the length the length of your elbow
to your your forearm on your wrist
rather if it fits in the hole perfectly
it will fit your waist and if you wrap
the jeans around your neck and it
both of the ends touch it will fit you
as well
because you know the um you know that
human proportion thing that stands like
this
yeah so yeah that the width of your the
width of your forearm is the same size
of your waist or similar size as you
wish and if you kind of
if you slit your neck and open it up the
circumference of that is the size of
your waist as well
so those are two ways to try on try on
jeans or trousers without actually
trying them on to know if they fit
ah okay i guess there's like a
gray error because i'm assuming like for
women for example if you've got like
massive hips
what i was like what if i'm fat that's
what he's going to say
like well my forum ain't doing nothing
because
maybe it's for like proportionate people
maybe but maybe not fat people maybe i
don't know but
this is why i've been told anyway so
i've tried it on because as soon as i
as soon as i saw it i tried it i put my
forearm in and it fit and i've wrapped
it around my neck it wrapped around so i
was thinking oh
wrap what are you doing so you obviously
you grab the two ends of the jeans or
whatever and you wrap
you get one tip again the other tip and
then wrap it around your neck right here
two tips touch like comfortably not like
tight then it will comfortably fit
around your waist
supposedly supposedly yeah so try out if
you guys let me know if it's fact or cap
fair play fact or cap
there's a new little one i like that